sagte wenn wir schon nicht so schlecht
hallo ihr lieben freund und herzlich
willkommen hier zu einem video wo
bestimmt direkt denkt was ist das denn
für eine scheiße also ich bin gerade
noch bei max und ich hatte mir gedacht
da wir jetzt gerade hier zusammen sind
könnten wir eigentlich so dass billiges
aufnehmen und zwar hat mir gedacht wir
machen eine runde bett was allerdings
dass ich nur die tastatur steuere und
macao die maus ihr seht jetzt mal maus
und tastatur eingeblendet und ja das
wird jetzt das ganze spiel über sehen
damit wir auch nicht schummeln können
und laufen weiter
wir sind ihr noch mit jemand anders
werden in einzel- und gehen werden
spielen wenn wir einmal zu spielen
ich denke sie denn
das muss ich so wie akon bleiben ja
freunde während aber umentschieden wir
gehen jetzt nämlich in die map
crystalline weil das eine acht- bis das
heißt wir spielen alleine
wohin wo einst nicken
okay okay okay ein neues werk leute
irgendwie haben wir mit shader und sonst
was wir alles zusammen benutzen
nein wir sind nicht letzter ist alles so
unglaublich langsam hin
wir haben können wir uns noch mal zwei
rettungsplattform wenn wir einmal ein
gutes equipment haben dann sollten wir
wert auf regel nichts zu verlieren okay
bis freitag was machen jetzt kann die
mittel jetzt werden betten zerstört wenn
wir die scheiße gewinnen möchte ich aber
20 aussehen wenn man nicht mitspielen
gedrückt nein ich darf direkt und boxen
kam max max max das ist jetzt sollen
auch noch dabei du bist aber wir sind
schon mal 41 leben nur noch vier das
heißt dennoch einer stimmt sind wir
schon auf dem podium wie er meint das
war schon richtig gut
und mittel auf die einzelnen jetzt als
er den bogen schwimmen lassen das gold
collection und bekommt er vom balkon
wachsen ich gehe nicht hingehen ich
hingehen ich hingehen muss einfach
passen wir lassen den kongressen
kontrakt mit dem auch jahrestrend jetzt
ok stop stop schnee kommt box ja jetzt
die haben schon den einen anderen kirche
macht also ich muss sagen mit mir an der
maus nein jetzt mir verloren
niemals ich glaube das nächste mal aber
seien wir froh sonst bist du nicht so
gut im bett wars jugendwehren bisher
einfach nichts gerissen es kam halt
einfach nur noch keiner erklären haben
wir schon leute besiegt wir würden
einiges reifen wenn er mich so ein
gewisser herr ab und zu mal runter
laufen würde
jetzt spielen von uns will man wenn ich
richtig runter gesprungen und haben uns
abgeschossen ich bin nicht
raus aus meinem haus
das hat mich ein falsch gemacht alles
was die bürger sagen unter was für
emittenten kennt sich überhaupt nicht
aus dem spiel
die rüstung an die das ist sogar jeder
der einmal im bett box gespielt hat weiß
circa das was man jetzt so machen würde
ich wette ich mit einem einzigen 1 boss
battle gegen dich gewinnen
mit meinem laptop das nicht
da kann ich nichts sagt ja also das
erste mal auf 5000 mal kommt er kommt er
kommt aber freuen
das liegt nicht nur an mir das ist
einfach so weil natürlich letztendlich
wenn ich alleine brettspiele fall ich ja
auch nicht einfach so runter von der
erde unterwegs erstellt dann laufen wir
nun vierter es ist ein kommen lassen
also muss man erst mal nachmachen von
acht stücke vierter zu werden
zu zweit gespielt
da müssen aber wenn wir zu viert zu
zweit ausarten ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen war ein bisschen chaotisch aber
wenn man es gedacht wir testen das hat
auch nicht vor sondern nehmen das halt
einfach mal so spontan aus wir zeigen
das ganze hier beim aufnehmen aussieht
ziemlich viele fenster haben vor allem
max hat auch noch einen bildschirm
deswegen gerne mal ein bisschen jetzt
hier rumgebastelt einfach wie man das
ganze sehen könnte ich hab auch gestern
einen blog gemacht wie das ganze hier
war weil wir bei einem schwimmbad und so
weiter und max hat auch einen blog
gemacht und so und wenn euch das video
gefallen hat es war vielleicht ein
bisschen chaotisch aber wenn sich doch
so gefallen hat würden wir uns über die
bewertung von max in der beschreibung
verlinkt